-It is so good to see you!
-Oh!
-This is the first,
like, in-person thing
I've done, really, like, on TV
other than the Golden Globes
And you know how that went
-You guys won a Globe for it
-Yeah.
We won a Globe for the Globes.
But --
-Are you happy to be back in
the world of business
and get to work again?
-I'm back to work.
-You're back to work.
-I mean, we had a year or two.
Was it two years?
-Isn't it a little weird
that there's been two --
it's happened --
March happened again?
-Yeah. It feels like we've
had about a year and a hal
of discovering
what we care about.
You know, tough times,
making bread,
being creative
in our sweatpants.
But it's time
to get back to work.
I'm back in the office.
-You're back in the office
-This -- You know, you are one
of my top work friends.
You're like in
my top-20 work friends.
-Of all time or currently?
-Just in New York.
-Okay.
-And, so, I'm excited abou
making sure
that this is very productive
'cause I need us to get --
I'm going to bill you
for this time.
-Okay, gotcha.
So this is not about --
We should not be frivolous
of our time here.
-I don't want any
personal questions.
I don't want to get personal
This isn't a time to
talk about life.
Work.
-Just work.
-Productivity.
-Okay.
-Numbers.
If we find a way to
get the sales up
that our company is going to do,
we need to make sure --
-So it seems like
you've maybe gone back to
a different kind of work
that you were doing before
because you don't seem very,
like, locked in on the terms
-Yeah, I forget what --
how work goes.
But I'm very excited to
talk with you about
solutions and ideas.
-Oh, God, that would be grea
to find some solutions.
I do -- I want to ask this
because it is very nice having
you back in New York City.
-Yeah.
-Summertime in New York City -
are you pro or are you con
-Love summertime
in New York City.
-Okay.
-My favorite city in the world
Love being here always.
A lot of people
are complaining about
a lot of stuff
in New York right now.
But you know what I love?
Construction.
-How so?
-Because I love
construction sites
because I do very well there
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Historically, has this been -
-Yeah, they're my people.
That's my group.
-Gotcha.
-Like, if I see scaffolding,
I'm like,
"What's going on over there?
-Oh, you'll go out of your way
-Then I go out of
my way just to say,
"What are you guys doing?"
-Gotcha.
-Yeah, because I don't think
that construction workers
are big fans of "Parks and Rec,"
but they are fans of my work
You know what I mean.
-Oh, that's great.
Yeah, yeah.
-They're fans of my work.
What's a common way that the
would let you know that --
-Well, no, I mean,
I do like that everyone
is out and about and talking
and seeing each other again.
Like, it is really great
to make eye contact with people.
And what's great about
New York is that
you can walk down the street
and someone can be like,
"Hey, beautiful."
And you can be like, "Hi."
And they can be like,
"Can I ask you a question?
And you're like, "No.
No, you can't ask me
a question."
It's that kind of give-and-take.
-Yes, like that
you can immediately --
It can immediately take
a left turn into this is,
"You've overstayed your welcom
with even your second sentence."
-It's best city in the world
to keep moving.
-Yeah.
-It's the best.
It's the best place
in the world.
-It is the best place
It kind of can be
oppressively hot,
but you've never minded that
-No. And, also, I was here
during the World Cup,
which was
awesome, walking around --
-How was that?
-Oh, it was so great.
I mean, just walking aroun
the streets, watching --
-Were you rooting?
Did you have
a rooting interest in the final?
-I didn't.
I was rooting for a good game,
which is certainly what we got
And Italians
and the English, the Brits
were, like, in full force in the
bars and pubs all over the city.
And I love little Prince Georg
in his little suit.
-Yeah. I read a headline
in "People" magazine
that he is like,
"No more shorts."
-He's not wearing shorts?
-No, 'cause he's 8 now.
It said he's 8.
And there was a big exclamatio
point like, "This is final."
-No more shorts?
-No more shorts.
Get used to the
little-suit look.
-He's not going to do well
at construction sites.
You got to wear shorts.
-You've got to wear shorts
-But it was exciting
that Italy won.
There was so many scooters
in the West Village
just going like, "Beep, beep!"
Like, just very -- Like,
there was a lot of people
in, like, handsome
suits and brown shoes
being like, "Beep, beep!
We won! Beep, beep!"
-Hey!
Like, carrying raviolis
and being like, "We won!"
And then their
beautiful girlfriend
being like, "Beep, beep!"
But that was great.
I like -- Did you watch
the World Cup?
-The European Cup, yeah.
-Oh, excuse me.
-We get a lot of -- We hav
this thing on the show now
where people --
-Wait. That was
the European Cup?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
I thought it was the World Cup
It was the European Cup?
-Yeah, it was the European Cup
-I thought it was the World Cup,
'cause the Olympics are
coming up, so I got confused
-Are you excited
about the Olympics?
-Very excited.
I know some people
don't like the Olympics.
And whatever they say about it
I agree with that, too.
But I do enjoy --
I'm very sad that
we're not going to see
Sha'Carri Richardson.
I think she's awesome
and an incredible athlete,
and I love watching her run.
And --
-Are you surprised?
How do you feel about this rule?
-Well, I am impressed by
the fact she can do anything
after smoking weed,
because I could do very little
back in the day.
-Yeah, because she
continued to excel.
-Yeah. Now, you spent
some time in Amsterdam,
so I'm sure you had
a minute or two
where you tried
a marijuana cigarette.
-Yeah. It never was --
I just get real tired.
-Tired.
-Yeah, I get real tired.
-So you don't run --
You don't sprint after that.
-No, no, no.
-But I would -- I mean,
I would like to go see a film.
Like, if it was, you know --
-Well, that did
happen to me one time.
But I will tell you that I had
a puff of a marijuana cigarette,
and then I went to see
"I Am Legend."
-Okay. The Will Smith --
-I wouldn't recommend it.
Yeah, that was
the movie with will Smith.
He was the only person
left in New York.
A dog is introduced
very early on,
and you know the dog
is not make it.
-You're not going to be like
"This is going to make it
to the end credit."
-The dog's not
gonna make it to the end.
What gets the dog?
Is it, like, a vampire perso
or something?
-Oh, yeah,
probably some kind of, like,
creepy alien
that is never explained.
-Right, right.
I got a question, though.
I've got an
"I Am Legend" question for you
-Yeah. Of course. I'm ready.
I run the website.
-No, but it's a hypothetical
-Alright.
-You're the last person
in New York.
-Mm!
-What do you do?
-It's so funny you say that.
My kid just asked me
that question.
He was like, "What if you were
the only person here?
What would you do?"
And I was like -- It was like,
"Walk around The Met?
Like, I don't know.
It would be a day,
and then I would have
a full breakdown.
-Right. Well, 'cause what
I like about New York is,
there's a -- you're surrounded
by people that are very good a
doing things that you can
then benefit from.
-Yeah. Like, am I going to
make my own pizza?
-No.
-What?
Going to the best pizza plac
and make my own pizza?
-Right.
-Like, no.
-Like, I'm not -- I mean,
I've watched, a thousand times
somebody at a bodega make my
egg-and-cheese sandwich.
-Yeah.
-It doesn't mean
I'm going to be able to do it.
-No. I think you and I both have
a quality where
we know what we're good at
-Yeah.
-And it's not any of those
things you said.
-Well, I think it will be
heartbreaking to think of
how little improv skills
would come in handy.
-Oh, my God, can you imagine
-Imagine -- The only thing
sadder than trying to do
an improv show
with people around
would be, like,
doing a bringer show
when there's nobody around
-You know what I would do?
I'd go into one of those,
like, cool mirror --
you know, like,
those mirrors that look like
there's 10 people and I'd do a
improv show with myself.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very hung over.
-Oh, yeah, that's right,
because you drank.
-Because I did day drinking.
We haven't aired it yet.
We're going to air it next week.
And we -- I mean, what is --
Back in the day,
when you were here,
what is a perfect
hung-over New York day
for Amy Poehler?
-Wow. Well, this is pre-kids
of course, 'cause,
you just, like -- There's no way
to be hung over
once you have kids.
Like, you just --
-You try to avoid it.
I mean, like,
at some point, you're like
"I don't even want to drin
for the fun of it."
-Yeah, you can't even say
you're hung over.
You're just like, "No, I'm not
I'm just throwing up
because I'm so happy."
But, you know,
the things that I used to us
to cure my hangover
are both gone,
because I would sit in
Pizzeria Uno and read magazines.
And they're both gone.
-Both Pizzeria Uno and --
-I mean, maybe Pizzeria Un
is still around,
and, you know,
I'm sure they're celebrating
Italy's European Cup win.
-I mean,
they're not going crazy.
-I mean, I can't --
I'm, like, reeling
that I thought it was
the World Cup.
I just didn't read
the fine print.
-That's fine.
But, I mean,
it was two European --
I mean, those teams
could have been in the final
of a World Cup, too, so...
-I feel like a couple guys tol
me it was the World Cup.
-Were they construction guys
-They were construction guys
They are like, "Hey!"
-We're they like, "Hey,
you just won the World Cup!"
-They were like,
"You got the World Cup of --
You know what I mean.
And I was like "Okay.
Oh, my God.
Thank you so much. Stop."
But, yeah, what did you do
for your hangovers?
What you are doing
for your hangover today?
-It was like having to work go
in the way a little bit.
But I definitely
want to have, like --
I would like to have
a very cold beer
and a very greasy hamburger.
I think that would be,
like, what I would like.
That might be how I try to
button this evening.
-And you drink the beer
and stick the
hamburger down your pants?
-And then I move around a lot.
-Throw the beer
over your shoulder,
stick the hamburger
down your pants.